so as we get into the conclusion of
spider-verse what we're going to find
here is that things are pretty
straightforward that again we pick up
right where we left off in the sense
that when we had left off in the last
video we had seen of course the cane had
been killed at several other spider
totems have been killed and that all
these rows were really leading to these
a spider the spider group converging on
the loom world in order to confront the
inheritors it might have been a little
more premature than was initially
planned but ultimately this is where we
end up at miss what we do when we pick
up in this video now of course Peter
Parker I guess chimes Ennis says that
Uncle Ben needs to get Gwen Stacy out of
there but Gwen Stacy chimes and it says
no and this is very important for Gwen
Stacy's character because what this is
basically doing is this Marvel telling
si Gwen Stacy is coming into her own
that this entire conflict this entire
spider verse was really more of a rite
of passage for Gwen Stacy it was a way
for her to step away from someone who
was still learning who was still coming
into her own and becoming a Spider Woman
to someone who was solidified as being
one of the foremost spider women that is
to say she knows what she's doing now
and so again what we do is we switch to
a more Lund and we're a lot as
continuing to I guess start with this
ritual he's drawing the blood of both I
guess Kaine and silk now again came to
previously been killed but silk is still
very much alive then even then we of
course see that for the most part this
ritual is two-thirds complete the only
thing that more Lund needs from here is
the blood of KM left side of the blood
of AB in G of the Scion and so what we
do is we see that as more London's
getting ready - I guess deal the killing
blow is he's getting ready to stab Benji
with a knife now the the knife is taken
away from him the knife is stripped away
and the knife is done so by the spider
totems or I guess the spider group who
have arrived
to confront more lun and so what happens
here is kind of a back-and-forth between
Peter Parker and Merlin and what Peter
Parker does is he basically calls
Moreland's bluff Peter Parker says that
he's noticed this entire conflict that
Morlan had never traveled to earth-616
to try to capture him more specifically
when lone had never actually traveled to
where Peter Parker was that regardless
of where he wasn't a multiverse to
capture him and so what Peter Parker
basically does is he tells more Lund
that he's scared here the more lund says
no more Lynde says that he's killed a
multitude of Peter Parker's but at the
end of the day we know Peter Parker's
right here that regardless of all the
various versions of Peter Parker that
more
may have killed that Peter Parker from
earth-616 is the only one that has
successfully been able to kill him
now of course we know that more lino
come back to life a Peter Parker had
demonstrated that when it comes to it
he's able to put his intellect to the
task and to do what needs to be done in
order to ensure that he comes out on top
and so again what we find is that in the
midst of this conflict while all these
various spider totems are fighting the
inheritors we find the more loom I'm
sorry that the cart arise now again Khan
was the cast-off Karn was the member of
the O'Hara tor family who had been cast
away by solace and again one of the
inheritor twins chimes in here and
saying that it seems to be that with
solace having been killed that the charm
or the spell that's been put in place to
keep Karn away is no longer effective
meaning that Karn can return at will and
so what happens here is that the initial
reactions of the inheritors is to
welcome Karn M to really believe they
can bolster their ranks using the the
improved and I guess effectiveness of
having Karn on their team but Khan says
no Karn says that he's constantly been
shunned aside that he's constantly been
pushed aside by the inheritors and so
what he says here is he's going to be
fighting on the side of the spider
totems and this is what he does he
begins fighting amidst all of them again
he begins confronting them but for Peter
Parker and more lon
this is really kind of a personal
conflict here this is something that
really seems to transcend the idea of
any possible ritual or any possible end
to the spider totems it seems to be the
for the most part Peter Parker wants to
bring this conflict between him and
Moreland to a close finally and so what
we see is that as a group as fighting as
a group is going again continuing to
combat one another that while Peter
Parker is fighting fighting more Lund
that he opens a portal and when he does
what he basically does here is drop more
Lund into the irradiated irradiated
earth and this is what happens with the
rest of the of the inheritors again with
Karn on their side the spider totems are
able to pretty much overpower the
inheritors and so as a result the
inheritors are pretty much rounded up
and they're taken to the irradiated
earth and they're put inside the bunker
that have been created on that planet by
Ezekiel Simms now again what this
basically does here is it means that the
inheritors have this kind of buffer the
inheritors are stuck inside of this
bunker and they can leave at least not
that we know of without succumbing to
the effects of radiation now we don't
know if the inheritors would somehow
find a way to to get
this bunker and perhaps create another
portal but what's happening here is a
lot of the spider group are really kind
of shocked to see that Peter Parker is
being a so merciful here and even the
inheritors are surprised to see this the
inheritors would believe under normal
circumstances that Peter Parker would
simply just kill them due to the fact
that they've killed so many spider
totems a Peter Parker simply says there
has to be a better way here and so what
we do is we begin to bring this story to
a close when we bring things to an end
what we find is in one of the more
interesting turn of events that Peter
Parker seems to cast aside the notion
that he and Cindy mu need to stay away
from each other and in fact he seems to
embrace her here of course he says that
he's feeling very sleepy and so as a
result he seems to embrace her at the
very least fall into her arms indicating
that what Marvel is going to do here is
effectively continue with the whole one
more day thing
keep Mary Jane Watson out of the picture
and bring Cindy moon in as the most
likely future love interest of Peter
Parker with that being said we're going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later please be sure to follow me
on Twitter there you can keep up with
all the updates from comics explained
and talk to me directly
[Music]